Aw!
Welcome to the 20th
anniversary celebration
of Hedwig and the Angry Inch.
I keep meeting people who
were affected by Hedwig.
Have you heard of Hedwig
and the Angry Inch?
And I'm like, that's me.
No way.
It just doesn't stop.
It's still relevant
and still beautiful.
It has fostered a
conversation with strangers
about meaning and purpose.
I've heard of multiple
people saying,
when I start dating someone,
if they don't like it,
we don't continue dating.
When people come up and say
it meant something to them,
it makes it more
impactful to me too.
It keeps giving.
It's like a personal ad that
never goes out of circulation.
Who are you?
Where do you exist?
When do you get to
make that decision?
Hedwig asked that
question with music,
which is the most visceral
way to ask a question.
That is the most empowering
compliment any artist can have,
is that it made
someone feel that they
could do something they didn't
know they could that has helped
them.